survival is the key to getting bred
straight up bro you never noticed that
no i totally noticed it bro the most
successful people i know came out of
course
i'm telling you if you don't know what
bad is you can never know what good is
cause you're always comparing to the
next two i'm not gonna compare myself
to kanye west hell no i ain't spitting
on no mic
i'm not selling those shoes i'm making
money on the grinder for nothing
i'm creating miracles out of dust you
feel me
so every day when i get up in the
morning i'm like bro
i'm gonna call everybody in my camp to
see what we got rocking
cause i'ma i'ma push you even though you
cashed a check for 100 g's
who cares get up daddy what you doing
you got to be hungry cause if you ain't
starving i don't want to [ __ ] with you
because how the [ __ ] am i hungry and i'm
good and you
you you got a little paper but you ain't
good you no good to me
you're trash so you got to be constantly
starving
to the dude that told me wake up and
smell the roses daddy i own rose
gardens i used to own nursery i owned it
all
i done it did it beat me look me up the
point is
that's boring it's whack
what am i gonna say hey i got five
million i'm gonna get 500 pounds i'm
gonna go eat some caviar
for what let's get bread let's get real
though
let people talk about you tell me when
you hit the block who you know to do
this yo what i do right there he nasty
that's what it's about it's about your
legacy when you're on the deathbed
you got stories for days when you got
stories for days with 100 [ __ ]
you good
remember we did this everybody could
spit a story
you know why cause you done did it if
you knew you were gonna die
in two days all right what would i do
what did you do what would you do all
day tomorrow
i'll call everybody i know look i'm
liquidating everything for free holla at
me hurry up
my kids my girl my mother boom this is
what they getting everybody
else got to come and and we're going to
bang and i'm going to look at you i'ma
say oh he's good at this your chest
let's play chess come get me
you good at banging let's get there you
go that pinball got pinball
whatever you do bang with me because you
got to remember me i came out
fighting swinging i'm not going to be
like oh my god i'm done
we've been done every day we closer to
being done
yeah but what's your favorite thing what
do you enjoy doing like what would you
spend the day doing you mean you would
just spend the day liquidating all your
assets
giving people money for free you just
give people your assets of course
because what does it really matter at
the end you're dead who cares
because my kids are gonna get bred
regardless my son got more money than me
is 28 years old he's iller than me
you feel me my daughter got two little
kids she's good she gets bread i got a
10 year old 12
my girl my wife she's good they're all
good because if you ain't good i'm not
with you
i'm not [ __ ] with no bums you feel me
cause i'm gonna make you better
because if i can't make you better i
failed and that's a good
legacy exactly you feel me if i'm
freaking with you right now
right now you're like bob in your head
are you blunted because you already know
oh my god i gotta highlight this dude
about blah blah blah right now you don't
even know what to talk about
because you're like oh you're mesmerized
because you already know
ain't nobody [ __ ] with me cause i'm
on some other [ __ ] i don't care
you feel me i will bang with anybody on
any topic
because if i get schooled that's cool
when i was in school
i remember like in fourth grade they
were talking about providences in canada
brian how do you spell nova scotia [ __ ]
n-o-v-a-s-c-o-t-i
no you're wrong oh [ __ ] why because no
capital n-o-v-a
capital s so i remember that [ __ ]
i remember in this third grade the
demonstrative pronouns this that these
and those
i don't give a [ __ ] about that i
remember because i got it wrong
when you get [ __ ] wrong you remember
because if you don't remember
your mistakes you gonna make the same
mistake twice and then they're going to
get you
they're going to stick you fax how do we
get paid
by schooling these people how to get
bred so you think you could sell some
courses or something to some people i
don't want to sell a course
why not you can make these
grant cardone he pushes businesses he's
he's a dream seller
he the thing is look you see this
[ __ ] jet
[ __ ] a million dollars a day ain't
nothing to me
scientology danny peep this if i gotta
charge you
to show you what i got then i ain't
worth nothing
i'm gonna show you for free so you could
make me though you get it
it's like this let me give you an
example if i know you can make me money
ten times
and you can make me ten g's ten times to
start and he could make me tense and i'm
eating because
we're gonna do like a pyramid you're
gonna bring people we're gonna eat off
everybody off my bread
a pyramid an mlm nah it's not it's like
this look let me give you an example
everybody's a client every single person
is a client
when you deal with real estate
everybody's a client it's like this look
yeah you know your mother your father
your brother your sister your cousin
your
your girl the girl you're [ __ ] her
sister whatever you know everybody right
now you know everybody yeah how can we
get what they got to make us money while
they're making money
everybody's happy right you get it you
understand the game
yeah or you don't feel me i don't know
you feel what i'm saying yeah i got it
all right look
here's what i'm gonna make money off my
girl's cousin
because if she has a house that her
mother left her and she ain't got
nothing in it
and she can't she can't afford the
payments she can't afford the taxes
she can't afford a rehab daddy gonna
come in and cop her set
and i'm gonna pay you you feel me
so everybody eats but if i gotta charge
you to school you
so basically i'm selling you a class
that ain't got no value so everybody i
got no confidence in my ability
cause i gotta rip you off if i gotta rip
you off what value do i got so everybody
you meet
out in the world has a value of course
the first thing when you look into
somebody's eyes you're trying to figure
out how you can do that the first thing
i look in your eyes is to see if you got
hearts if you could freak with me
see where you're at mentally physically
dominating me how can i dominate you
mentally to [ __ ] with me on my field
get it yeah i get it but you're trying
to figure out how you can make
money with these how how you can
leverage these people why wouldn't you
because
because what else am i going to do play
tea set with them honestly i don't care
what you do
what you do in your regular life has no
value to me how am i going to eat what
you do
right i could only eat if we could get
loot if i can't get bread i'm not with
you when we were at the
when i met you at that bar the other day
yeah when that lady was talking crazy
but that chick right there the first
thing you said to her she was a real
estate lady you could tell
and the first thing you said to her is
like listen what deals do you got that i
could buy from you right now
and she was like to be honest to be
honest probably she was trying to make
small talk with you and then you were
like listen i don't want to make small
talk
tell me what deals i could buy from you
right now give me the addresses
getting right to the point yeah of
course you know what it is
let me tell you another thing i learned
in my lifetime and i've been doing bills
since i was
five years old you could ask anybody who
knows me
shoot celo play dice play spades
poker push whatever comic books baseball
cards
you name it the point is this if you
step to me
and your game is whack and you ain't got
none off of me
the [ __ ] i got to deal with you for you
know i mean unless
i could clean you up and show you how to
get it i could school people how to get
it with nothing i like to deal with
broke people by the way
of course because this is why i'm
motivated right of course because if you
got mad bread what you gonna do
try to bang with me mentally right
you're trying to out i bang with anybody
you feel me what you gonna tell me oh i
do this i do that i don't give a [ __ ]
what you do
what you eat don't make me [ __ ] how we
getting it
cuz most people who get it they're
they're they're shook
cause they're scared second they don't
want to share their bread because
they're greedy
and they don't know to get cause like i
told you from day one
if you don't know what bad is you never
know what good is
wait here's what i'm gonna tell you what
does that mean uh here's what that means
let's pretend like i told you from the
rip
let's pretend your father is worth 100
million dollars you went to private
schools
you got went to school limousines
everything that you did was
force-fed to you to get bred right
your dad cuts you off gives you a
million dollars throws you in a crib
boom now in your head oh my god i could
only buy a three and a quarter beamer
i could only afford this crib [ __ ] i
only got 800 stacks left
you think you're hit bro cause you don't
know what the bricks are about
you never ate out of a bag you never had
a knuckle up for five dollars
you never had to walk this you're the
block cause you got your shell head
adidas out and they trying to stick you
you never go to you from catholic school
or public school
the first day you get there do look at
you yo daddy i'm a i'm gonna stick you
for your chain
hit him in the head real quick
immediately come get me now
so the point is if you've never done bad
you don't know what bad is so the point
is i like to deal with people who've
done real real bad
because then we gonna get it because
they have the knowledge how to survive